[Music]
always so much fun when our cooking
confidence coach Nanny Bobby joins us in
studio thanks to Chapman Automotive the
sponsors of this segment and you know
it's so often we talk about cooking
confidence right right and it's hard to
get that confidence for a lot of people
who didn't cook all the time or haven't
cooked a lot right exactly and if you
didn't grow up generational cooking or
if you didn't grow up going to home
economics and if you're not a natural
foodie where do you start so I have an
Annie Bubby tidbit for that but I want
to tell you I am not a foodie I do not
cook because I love food I cook because
I love people I like that concept and so
it's my love language and the best place
to start is with appetizers so if we
want to start we're doing old-fashioned
crescent rolls just take the crescent
rolls open up that little package I love
these by themselves already Yes and this
is
rated so we're going to take the
triangles like that that we're going to
take this butter that's melted put in
about a tablespoon garlic powder mix it
up and then you're just going to dip the
triangle right in here and like this
bring it right over here we're going to
take a teaspoon of onion right in there
we're going to sprinkle it with Parmesan
cheese a little bit more because I like
things really cheap I am with you I
agree and now you're going to just roll
up the triangle just like that and onto
the cookie sheet sprinkle with a little
bit of Parmesan cheese
and let me just tell you you can do
appetizers have friends over for drinks
and apps and then if you want order
pizza afterwards or you know go out for
dinner but start with appetizers so here
they are done
and let me just pull them off for
cookies oh yeah they look good because
what we're going to do here
we go
how do you like that those look great
all right and we're just going to cut
them in threes or maybe even fours and
we're gonna pop them on this beautiful
platter which has Melissa's Produce oh
high tangerines which are in season
right now and I always like to tell you
what's in season and these beautiful
Ojai tangerines look how pretty all of
this looks and last week we did Salt Fat
and acid and so the acid is the
tangerines you've got a lot of fat and a
lot of salt with the parmesan cheese and
this my friend is good enough to taste
that's beautiful did you tell us what
these leaves are yes they are tangerine
leaves okay yeah that is a beautiful
spread right there do you want to taste
absolutely okay and this goes great with
wine or beer by the way right like if
you're a beer guy or a wine girl
or a soda or whatever
yes isn't it fabulous that's it so happy
that you're enjoying it and it is a
great way to entertain without getting
too and it's five ingredients five
ingredients that's it where can people
find this information uh on
nannybubby.com on Nanny Bubby Instagram
on nannybubby Facebook and you can go to
melissas.com to get your oh hi
tangerines they're only in season for a
brief amount of time and so you want to
make sure that you buy them now I love
it absolutely love it always labor chips
good to have you here check out Nanny
Buddy's kitchen and Garden on social
media and as we said online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
Chapman Automotive for sponsoring this
segment thanks Kendall good to see you